>> Hey, YouTube. My name is Bruce Sewell.
I'm senior vice president and general counsel
of Intel Corporation. And I wanted to answer
the question about whether President Obama
is likely to improve the state of the world
in 2009. Quite simply I think, the answer
to that is yes. But you need to be a bit careful
with the metrics by which you are going to
measure success. If we set the bar at stemming
the rising tide of unemployment or putting
liquidity back into the banking system, then
I think it's still far too early to say with
any certainty that we are going to see those
kinds of events in 2009. On the other hand,
if you measure this or you define success,
as improving the relationship between the
American government and the rest of the world,
or even more specifically improving the relationship
between the American government and its own
citizens. Then I think the answer is a bit
more easy, and perhaps even self evident.
I'm optimistic that we are going to sow the
seeds for improvement in 2009, but I'm less
sure that the world will be in a position
to reap that harvest within just the next
12 or 18 months.